there's a lot that holds us back from
trying out psychotherapy there's the
idea that you have to be a little mad or
Harbor some huge and strange problem to
go and see a therapist it can be hard to
see that therapy isn't in fact for the
select disturbed few it's for everyone
because actually it's entirely ordinary
to be rather confused a bit anxious and
sometimes challenged by relationships
family life in the direction of your
career so really the only qualification
for going to therapy is to be a normal
human being there's also the worry about
the strangeness of it all it'll be you
and someone you've never met to whom
you're expected to divulge nothing less
than your inner life why not talk to a
friend well firstly because friends are
properly trained to listen as one will
have noticed they interrupt a lot and
secondly because it's sometimes easier
to tell someone who has no prior
knowledge or expectations of you the big
and important things about who you are
furthermore therapists are the last
people ever to judge their concept of a
normal human being is far more expansive
than lap Hells by society at large they
know how unusual and surprising we are
especially around sex and anxiety the
whole training takes them into the
recesses of their own and other's minds
they know how surprising we can all be
it doesn't frighten them it intrigues
and motivates them that's why they
became therapists in the first place
they are in the end interested in mental
health that means in helping out then
there's the cost isn't it all a fortune
it might be the price of going out for
dinner with friends which is both a lot
and and not so much it really just
depends on the value you place on it
this is the crux of it therapy is
valuable because so many of our problems
come down to not having enough insight
into how our minds work what we want
what we fear why we act the way we do
and are overwhelmed by certain feelings
the goal of therapy is self-knowledge by
talking a lot to someone who listens
very carefully over many weeks you come
to deeper insights into the mind you
inhabit
patterns start to emerge a particular
way of approaching relationships or
dealing with defeat a recurrent not very
helpful approach to jealousy an ongoing
thing with your sister or father this is
the stuff of therapy knowing how to live
isn't an instinct we're not born with it
it's a skill and one of the places you
learn it is in the outwardly slightly
unusual but in fact deeply normal and
productive setting of a therapist's
office it isn't a sign of disturbance to
go to therapy it's the first sign of
sanity and of a proper grown-up
commitment to mental health
you